طعا ربما يشهد جنوب لبنان خلال هذه الساعه
هدوءا حذرا بعد تصعيد في منسوب العمليات
العسكريه من جانب حزب الله وايضا من
الجانب الاسرائيلي خلال الساعات ال 24
الماضيه التي شاهدت 13 هجوما من جانب حزب
الله على مواقع اسرائيليه مختلفه اخرها
كان اليوم اربع عمليات على مواقع مختلفه
في القطاع الغربي وال والاوسط من جنوب
لبنان استهدف حزب الله باحد الصواريخ التي
تحمل راسا
متفجرا تزن بين 250 و500 غم من المتفجرات
تجمعا للجنود قرب منطقه جل العلام وهي
قباله بلده الناقوره وهذا الموقع يعد
حاميه لايضام استوطنت الاسرائيليه في
الجليل الغربي حزب الله ايضا شن ثلاث
عمليات اخرى مستهدفا تجمعات للجنود
والمواقع ب الصواريخ والاسلحه المناسبه
وفقا للبيانات المتتاليه التي اعلنها
اليوم وكان الحزب شن تسع عمليات هجوميه في
منطقه في مناطق مختلفه من الجنوب الليله
الماضيه كان معظمها وقع في القطاع الغربي
والاوسط بعد ان شن الحزب سلسله هجمات على
المواقع الاسرائيليه المختلفه وقال انه
حقق اصابات في هذه الهجمات المختلفه وكانت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه قد اغارت
على منزلا في بلده بيت ليف هذه البلده
التي تقع بعمق 6ه كيلومترات استهدف
الطائرات الاسرائيليه منزلا فيها اعلن
بعدها حزب الله عن استشهاد اربعه من
مقاتليه يجري تشييعهم هذا اليوم في بلدات
مختلفه من جنوب لبنان ايضا حزب الله كان
استخدم صواريخ لاول
مره يصل مداها الى عده كيلومترات في منطقه
الجولان السوري المحتل هذه الصم يخ التي
اطلقها هي ايرانيه الصنع وتحمل رؤوسا
متفجره بزنه 50 كيلوغراما وهذا الموقع هو
الاول مره يستهدف من جانب حزب الله في هذه
المنطقه التي تشرف على مزارع شبع
اللبنانيه المحتله